guys everyone loves an underdog and
there are a few better places to find
truly fear jerking Cinderella stories
than eSports now no matter what your
team or your regional allegiances are
you have to admit these are some of the
most iconic moments in eSports history
now of course the most iconic moment in
eSports history was the moment you saw
me wearing the shirt you can get your
own at the score eSports new online
merch department a truly iconic link
will be pinned in the comment section
below
[Music]
so from little-known teams making
miraculous runs on their games biggest
stage to underperformers looking to turn
a season around here are the top 10
Cinderella stories in eSports we kick
off our list with the team that turned
League of Legends on its head in 2012
the Taipei assassins came into the World
Championships with no international
experience and many were unsure if their
regional dominance would translate to
the game's biggest stage but they held
tough beating the surging najin white
shield before toppling tournament
favorites Moscow 5 to earn a spot in the
finals diamond price goes down the
inhibitor is open the double kill comes
out fast on five looking very grim right
now taipei assassins look to take down
the last Nexus 10 and they will trap
Moscow 5 for the League of Legends
championship playoffs after losing a
back-and-forth game 1 against Korean
juggernauts azubu frost TPA would go on
to win the next three games to become
League of Legends second world champions
coming in at number 9 on our list are
dota 2 darlings ad finem the Greek squad
certainly didn't enter 2016 s Boston
Major as favorites after barely making
it through the EU qualifiers and did
seem like their time at the tournament
would be cut short after struggling
through the group stage of a home and
they take game number three what has
been an intense series but no one could
have predicted what came next as the
Greeks came out strong beating Ruby LGD
foreveryoung and digital chaos enroute
to an unexpected playoff berth
dear
while they came up short against og in
the finals Advan ins run will go down as
one of the scenes best cinderella
stories
Evo is an opportunity for legends to
cement their status and new players to
make their mark which is why the 8th
entry on our list belongs to Luffy's
historic run at Evo 2014 he was knocked
into the loser's bracket early into
ultimate street fighter force bracket
but Luffy wouldn't be denied his shot at
glory as his loser's bracket run saw him
take out taquito momochi momochi sent
home in seventh place in Fudo on route
to the grand finals in two unbelievable
sets with a character that many believed
was low tier Luffy managed to best bone
chin and secure the first-ever Evo
Street Fighter win for Europe after 11
grueling rounds in the losers bracket
going through all those guys including
Snake Eyes having a down-to-the-wire
match with Snake Eyes and Luffy has
taken it
evolution 2014 from Europe from staring
down relegation to facing off against
the best in the world
the 7th entry on our list belongs to
cloud nines incredible gauntlet run to
secure a spot at Worlds in 2015 with
incarnation now known as Jensen taking
over the team's midlane duties during
the summer split cloud and I went
through some growing pains and only
narrowly avoided relegation but thanks
to their second place spring split
finish they still had a shot to make it
to Worlds as the 4th seed in the NA
regional qualifiers we get into this
North
regional qualifier cloud9 vs. gravity
expended rec you said roughly a month
before these turns since these teams
have played I'm sure they're ready and
raring to go with a reverse sweep
against gravity and they are able to
come back from D to O or I should say o
to that gravity put them in to go 3-2 to
vs. gravity in the first call it game of
the North American summer split cloud
nine are moving on to take on impulse
followed by a reverse sweep against team
impulse they give up the series cloud
nine get through first sweep and they're
gonna face team liquid into dominant win
over Team Liquid
cloud9 shocked the region and made their
third consecutive world's appearance
[Music]
coming in at number six is beyonds
incredible GSL season to win in 2016
after qualifying for code s buin was one
of only three teen 'less players in the
tournament is that second fire off the
current group say it is beyond and he
qualified after night beating 4.30
fourth they don't really that strong of
a player but it's still an impressive
result you'd be Gann is climbed by
qualifying for the round of 16 against
la serie before defeating SOS to top his
group and make it to top eight holes a
little bit indecisive he's gonna kill a
lot 17 workers and the stalkers Jeezy's
away you know what I mean this is this
is kind of this this move seems
surprising like wow I can't believe
horse @gg they're fighting his way
through the tournament beyond once again
face down the dominant Protoss in the
finals after losing Game one
Hyun went on to stun the Starcraft world
completely dismantling his opponent in
the next four games to become the first
team 'less player to win a major korean
league yacht is just too good with his
control this is a tasteless SOS is done
yeah
my god Dimas beard is the gsl code as
champion in League of Legends wildcard
teams at Worlds are largely swept aside
by the major regions but the number 5
entry on our list flip that narrative on
its head
Albus knocks Luna were grouped with
Europe's G to North America CLG and
Korea's Rox Tigers at the 2016 World
Championship but the CIS upstarts were
unfazed by their group mates and managed
to topple not only CLG and g2 but the
dominant Korean team as well
[Applause]
it's just took down the rock
with those wins Albus knocks Luna became
the first wild card team ever to make it
out of the group stage at Worlds and
while they would lose to h2k in the
quarterfinals they left their mark on
the game's biggest stage hey guys
they're from wild car and they have told
you before being underdog doesn't mean
being a loser on set so coming in at
number four on our list is another even
more miraculous world's birth by cloud 9
[Music]
cloud 9 2018 summer season saw the bench
three star players and experiment with
their roster at first things look bad
but midway through the split things
begin to click and they qualified for
Worlds after a successful gauntlet run
but it was at the 2018 World
Championships where cloud 9 made history
after making it out of a tough group c9
took down the Africa freaks 300 in
quarterfinals and were part of the
reason no Korean team made it to the
World Finals for the first time since
they got a server
we'll make it to the semi-final 3-0 oh
yeah they're also the first na team to
make it past the quarterfinals since
season 1 the 3rd spot on our list
belongs to the North American team who
proved the counter-strike world wrong in
Boston cloud9 quickly 3 owed their way
to the new legend stage after losing
their first two games it seemed like top
8 would be out of reach for North
America at yet another major but three
incredible wins later
cloud 9 reached the new champion stage
[Music]
[Music]
with top 8 secured North America's last
hope vested g2 then SK and finally
defeated the newly formed super team
faze clan securing na s first major
title they weren't the favorites they
were the underdogs they were a heavy one
but a fitted for North America skill
dude don't want em a job the runner-up
spot on our list harkens back to
Starcraft's early days in 2006 we wore
was in the midst of the rain of its
fourth Vanja wada whose dominance
inspired the title savior but in the
2006 MSL finals
one young Protoss player named Basu
would go on to stunned the Starcraft
world in a matchup heavily favoring
Savior zerg race be sue did the
unthinkable
not only did visa win III oh the game's
most dominant player and the
unconventional strategies he employed
would go on to change the way that
people play pvz the International is the
absolute pinnacle of dota 2 which is why
our number-one entry belongs to a team
who defied the odds after losing two of
their best players just before the
tournament oh gee were forced into a
speedy rebuild and while they managed to
secure Europe's only qualification spot
at TI many thought that would be the
lone bright spot for the ragtag group
and boy they were wrong
in a group with tournament favorites oh
gee managed to squeak into the upper
bracket from there
oh geez sheer determination and force of
will saw them barrel through a number of
tournament favorites all the way to the
grand finals and while you know the rest
[Applause]
well guys that's our list from this week
now if we missed out on your personal
favorite Cinderella story from the
history of eSports will of course let us
know in the comment section below do
leave a like sub to the channel and I
will see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]